hi guys it's self everybody calm down
okay same going after that too sometimes
okay okay I'm in a pickle right here
well not literally but I'm in a pickle i
I want to place box but Webber's large
rocks just keeps crushing on me should I
risk it or should I not to risk it or
not to risk it should i okay I'm just
gonna do it it's something about you
girl
oops I just I just realize them ruining
no yeah well no yeah I'm just doing rock
work and and the webos rocks rocks still
wasn't crushed so I'm really client
about that because this set is something
that you can't burst okay [ __ ] crush
[ __ ] crush okay I'm I'm done I'm I'm
done i I I'm done
okay I'm gonna start all over because
the game crashed okay hi and so now I
need to do something else and not use
those rocks anymore because I don't
trust them I'm about everything that's
what for chance that when the fappening
happened yeah that was like all over the
[ __ ] news that was all the [ __ ]
news people are like who is this
Porchester guy just explaining all the
[ __ ] just being a [ __ ] because he
quote-unquote knew what he was talking
about no but I am trying to build a roof
for this building so could you please
stop distracting me because I need to do
some work okay thank you
well I mean thank you thank you thank
you your your your wish is my command
you gotta record this though
just listen and enjoy wait for it okay
okay okay it's very nice enough of that
please show her you better cube [ __ ] you
better have that on tape now nope oh I
could add panda coasters in here need a
gate oh no you cannot add him I'll find
a way that was like wonderful okay you
wanna make a bet of what would happen
first if I add panda coasters you want
to make a bet yeah okay that's bad I bet
that he's gonna wait no no that question
is is he gonna talk about the patriarchy
and misogynistic people or is he gonna
read for Chen green texts that's the
question isn't it yeah or is he called a
hotline okay I'm gonna say that are we
talking about panda coasters yeah all
right wait he probably won and you
probably will actually hang up on the
call that's the most like I bet is that
he doesn't join yeah same okay I'm mom
and I gotta add panda coasters all right
here we go and yes I was correct you two
enjoying nice money there
oh my god he joins hi I don't know the
whole system okay oh wait wait wait
no I mean yeah something just happened
that we've been talking about for a very
long time now you're actually in my life
and what my let's play right now so I'm
welcome yes it was white now that's this
video well the the beautiful music
better be in the episode as well though
like seriously
so so so this is let's play right now
yeah we're doing yeah yeah mate
yeah can I add the number no an idea
yeah we need some beautiful music in
that's it's it going to do it we're
going to throw a few tall I'm just gonna
keep adding it in it's like it's like a
paid number if I try to call it it says
I don't have enough money on my skype to
call it you know what fine with me watch
us pay a [ __ ] iPad line I will recall
this group will do it nice music your
match
say hello hey what's going on hello
what's going on yo man just took my dick
token why people on Steam what's up
[ __ ] horny as hell
somebody that your match ok ok that's
but it's ass been enough of that
oh my [ __ ] god can you turn off the
gay hotline because it's gay oh my god
alright you need to keep that egg cuz
wait cause it says your badge say hello
you started ranting over gay ha amazing
timing amazing timing you know let it go
no collect reverse charge or third-party
calls you turn okay thank you - no Oh
Mike
no you're just gonna I'm just gonna use
catfish Cove because nobody uses that
side it's a very underrated set that
nobody uses are you that you know what's
worse than getting copyrighted by you
know they're not Warner Music Group's
over at what getting copyrighted by
Universal I think you kind of gave the
clue of that away yeah I switch to
around oh wait I forgot I forgot I
forgot I'm stupid I didn't even add the
Eve's [ __ ] oh wait they're actually in
this pack oh wait no no no no no I've
got the wrong one
have you ever appeared in someone's eye
what kind of question is that
hey 4chan oh yeah I say dude all right
okay you made a very bad decision I am
trying to record my let's play could ya
at least behave like you're actually
20-something this is how your 20 year
olds actually someone's I know
yeah but sorry I know yeah the America
not everything around Michael and not
everyone around my place is stupid like
you
20 year old love play dirty Potter
audiobooks and talk about feminism and
feminist [ __ ] oh [ __ ] I got them
started here comes another Japanese
earthquake right okay hi everyone it's a
bunch of white boys in a khole no [ __ ]
we black
don't actually count that in there now
we're gonna let that slip and include
that but it's okay it's okay everyone
it's in the 3-1 no it's okay because we
use the AC defense what defense defense
we don't say [ __ ] we say [ __ ] with
an AIDS that changed everything there is
light shine through yeah and put the cap
in your butt say hallelujah oh I hate a
wine I try to build something then I
build it and then I'm like actually no
and I have to remove it all over again
and I figured that I've wasted I just
wasted two minutes of my life that I'll
never get back and then I think about
that and I'm not like huh
no that's not good it's over he taught
me how to make CS you're welcome
actually III don't do it for anything
other than the YouTube money obviously
I'm aspiring to be the next PewDiePie
don't you boy up in it Oh watch me swag
and watch me roll watch me crank that
Superman and soldier boy and oops I'm
[ __ ] up ya know
every time I try to add something it
just looks like poop and I don't like it
damn it what do I do with this roof okay
this is not getting anywhere nothing
because it's a good thing that I okay
I'm not even gonna turn this into a time
lapse I'm just gonna record just gonna
upload this as it is for the
conversation or something like not that
that's a great thing but I'm just not
getting anywhere it's very annoying I've
got an idea
why I don't know why I've got an idea
though probably some chemicals in my
brain doing an interesting complex stuff
law saying the law in a real okay
okay I'll give you I'll give you a piece
of my mind okay law is is is is means
laughing out loud you use it in a chat
on the internet where you want to say
that you find something funny and
actually laughed in real life it don't
say law in real life because that
doesn't make sense
why okay I'm Internet just I was in the
middle of my rent about that and then
internet decided to nope arm silver at
work arm silver at swang arm silver at
swaying arm silver at sweating making
YouTube money making YouTube money what
making YouTube money making YouTube
money swag mic he doesn't need his name
up in lights you just want to be heard
whether it's the beat or the mic you
just feel so in like everybody else
alone it's like that some people no
[ __ ] before knows the code it's not
about the salary it's all about reality
of making some noise making a story make
a choice distance this is that were the
worst dick stays up our quick success
collects stays up of course they're not
gonna they're not gonna make boner
reference this would sort of make sense
no rap sex all that [ __ ] no no you don't
get the point
rap it's not about just sex it's about
okay I'm gonna I'm gonna give that a
couple of main core points of rap music
today very important point is the women
the women need to be over sexualized and
they need to you need to refer to the
women as so-called [ __ ] and it's
pretty it's pretty interesting
and then you've got money which you have
loads of you're making almost dank yo
you making fat stacks tank in the bank
to you know drugs and all that and
you smoke weed everyday' and and by the
way America get your [ __ ] together
legalize that and then there's what else
do we have
did I forget about anything Wow we've
got we've got drugs
we've got sex we've got women we've got
expensive cars and money I think that's
it's yeah that's pretty much every rap
song I don't know the general shape is
actually not that bad it does need some
more details on it but I'll do that some
other time because I don't want to
record any more now so yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah I'm gonna stop
it right here burn there's anything more
you want to say I know ever well thank
you okay then say bye bye bye bye okay
then yeah so until next time everyone